من القيامه الصغرى الى كارثه 2023 الوجع
نفسه والمشاهد وعينها بين عام
ولكن شيئا اساسيا تغير بعد 24 عاما وجود
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
الزلزال الذي وقع جنوب تركيا فجر الاثنين
وخلف الاف القتلى والجرحى والعالقين تحت
الانقاض ليس الاول بطبيعه الحال لكنه
الاسوا منذ عقود
لكن لماذا هذا التاريخ المليء بالكوارث
الطبيعيه في تركيا الجواب بسيط تقع تركيا
في منطقه تشهد نشاطا زلزاليا وهو من بين
الاعلى في العالم اذ تتموضع على خط صدع
عميق
وفي عام
1999 كانت تركيا قد شهدت في السابع من شهر
اغسطس زلزالا اعتبر من اكبر الزلازل في
التاريخ التركي بلغت شدته 7.4 درجه واستمر
لمده 45 ثانيه ليسجل لك اطول مده زمنيه
لزلزال بتاريخ البلاد وامتد هذا الزلزال
على حوض بحر مرمره كافه حيث شعر به سكان
العاصمه انقره وازمير كما تسبب ايضا في
خسائر فادحه بالارواح والممتلكات
[موسيقى]
بلغت حصيله الوفيات حينها خمسه وعشرين
الفا لكن كثيرا من صور تلك الكارثه لم
تحفظها الذاكره البشريه لانها حصلت قبل
عصر التواصل الاجتماعي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]